whether it's driving cars feeding and
milking cows or performing surgery
robots are stepping up to the task and
cracking into a range of markets their
ranks have swelled to 1.7 million in the
world but the boom brings some urgent
questions do robots have rights if so
what are they what ethical principles
should bind them can they be held liable
for accidents for MEP s it's time to
tackle these issues the first thing is
that you always have to tell people that
robot is not a human and the robot will
never be a human robot can show empathy
but you will never feel empathy you can
be dependent physically because you need
a robot to do some fast but you must
never think that a robot is a human and
that he loves you they may be devoid of
emotions but they are not exempt from
rules if a bot causes harm the damage
should be compensated not just by the
boat's owner but also its designers
producers and users at the center of the
debate are self learning robots designed
to make decisions on their own MEP s
have suggested mandatory insurance for
these as they are less predictable than
earlier generations so far legislation
on the civilian use of robots is
virtually non-existent in most member
states MEP s hope to bring the European
Union up to speed
[Music]